(footsteps)
(woman groans)
- Good to know you haven't
gotten any stronger
since we broke up.
That was a weak-ass punch.
- Yo, Melinda, check this out.
- Oh my God.
Oh, God, that hurt so bad.
Why would you throw that at me?
(brass fanfare)
(gunshots)
- Why do you think Sahara would
just trash her room and leave?
- I don't know.
I thought that we were getting along.
Unless she was kidnapped.
But who would kidnap her?
- Who wouldn't?
I just realized how creepy that sounded
and I retract that statement.
- It does appear that there
were signs of a struggle.
- Wait, can we circle back
to who would kidnap Sahara?
- I don't know, like North Korea, Russia?
Whoever kidnaps spies, normally.
- Sahara's a spy?
God damn, that's (beep) cool.
- I gotta stop telling people that.
- Well, if she's kidnapped
then we gotta find her.
- Or, we could call the police
and they could find her.
- Or we use Find my iPhone.
- Or the police.
- Quit being such a wimp, come on.
- What, I'm not a wimp.
You're a wimp.
- Oh, please.
Why are you selling your car?
- There was a spider on my steering wheel.
I am not a wimp.
Hack her phone, do it now.
- Already did.
- Oh, wow.
Movies don't lie, it
really takes no time at all
to hack somebody's phone.
- I know, right, it's crazy.
Okay, turning on Find My iPhone now.
- Why kidnap me?
- Because you're--
(cell phone vibrates)
Are you kidding me?
No one took her phone.
Susan?
Vlad?
You are all useless.
(phone breaks)
Especially you, Vlad.
- I got a hit.
- Let's go.
- You good?
- You're just mad I
dumped you, aren't you?
- Wow, here we go.
Classic Sahara, making
everything about her.
- Then why am I here, Zoe?
- Because you're an asset
to the U.S. government
and that makes you an asset to me.
- Why?
What do you want with the government?
- I'm sorry, do you
think this is Bond film?
And I'm gonna tell you my evil plan
in a giant monologue
while your partner bursts
through the door to save you?
Goddamnit, Vlad.
- I brought lemonade in
case anyone was parched.
(ominous music)
- Okay, this is a bad idea.
I'm definitely calling the cops.
- I thought you weren't a wimp.
- Okay, there's a different
between being brave
and being stupid.
- Not that much of a difference.
Leroy Jenkins.
- Matt?
- Hey, just coming to save you.
- But, let's hurry up and save
her because I don't know--
- Let's not and say we did.
- Jesus, Zoe.
Did you get your one-liners
from a nineties book of cliches?
- Shut up.
Come any closer and I'll
slice this dorky girl's neck.
- Slice my neck?
- Wow, that is one weak--
(police sirens blare)
- Okay, they said we're free to go.
- Good, I just want to go
home and lay on the couch
and never leave the house again
but I guess that makes me a wimp.
- Are you kidding?
Your wimpiness saved us.
When you passed out and
collapsed in her arms,
it left her confused and vulnerable
so that I could deliver the final blow.
- Like a boss.
- [Sahara] We definitely tag-teamed her.
- We did?
- You killed it, dude.
- I'm a wimp?
- Oh, yeah, the wimpiest.
- I'm a wimp.
- Okay, stop yelling.
- Yes, let's get an ice cream.
Who wants an ice cream?
- I'm so hungry, yes.
(exciting music)